welcome back to Pittsburgh on any given
day there are a lot of news stories
which make me very unhappy not least to
which Arsenal nil Brighton three well we
weren't intrigued into private grief um
but they proved that common sense is
dead
just today we learned that a biological
man entered the 2015 female University
boat race no one was told no one was
allowed to ask
we were told that prison guards have
been banned from calling prisoners
convicts in case it upsets them upsets
convicts
with over 10 percent of teenagers want
to change gender but a third of
teenagers have been taught in schools
that some women have penises what is all
this
why is the world going so completely
nuts well my next guest is an expert on
this phenomenon of the world going nuts
Professor gadsad is the best-selling
author of parasitic mind how infectious
diseases are killing common sense and
also the sad truth about happiness and
he joins me now again thank you for
coming on so just to warm things up I
thought I'd play a little clip of you
talking about me in 2018 let's take a
listen to this
Morgan is a treasonous cretan I don't
care about him as an individual but I
greatly care about his mindset for it is
the singular cause that has led us to
the current conundrum that we face every
day that idiots and enemies of Reason
such as Morgan have a voice in the
public sphere as a day that we inch
closer to violence
well ironically gathered that that
comment as she did move me to near
violence I'm joking and actually we have
found since then a lot of common ground
I know so I'm not going to labor the
point uh other than you clearly I just
as I don't even remember what that was
about I have no idea what you were
talking about and no one can find out so
you clearly just had a view about me
that you know what it's fine I have
views like that all the time about
people but I'm glad to have you on the
show and I think you've got a lot of
issues we actually share a lot of
similar thoughts about this what is
going on when we see things like 10 of
teens want to be transgender in some way
when you see that a a a male biological
rower took part in a very high profile
race without anybody knowing that this
was actually a man sitting in a female
boat
um when you see all this
how do we explain it and where does this
where does this end
yeah so it all well first thank you for
having me Pierce uh it all stems from
regrettably I'm saying this as a
professor it all stems from from the
University ecosystem it takes academics
and intellectuals to come up with some
of the
uniquely dumbest ideas and so each of
these idea pathogens that I discussed in
the book post-modernism militant
feminism social constructivism sort of
erase a bit of the edifices of reason
that for most of us constitutes common
sense so post-modernism for example
argues that there are no objective
truths even things that the average
three day old pigeon would recognize as
biological fact is actually Up For
Debate and this is how we end up erasing
all of the common sense that gives us
shared meaning so that men now who have
nine inch penises can be women they
simply have to declare themselves women
and voila they become women yeah I mean
it's completely insane but you're right
facts have have been eroded in this
process where people can put their hand
up and talk about my truth as if somehow
their version of the truth which of
course is statistically factual that's
all point of truth that they can have a
version of that which isn't fact based
it's just feeling based
exactly and this is why I I basically
say that all of these idea pathogens
they free us from the pesky shackles of
reality right I don't wish to be
constrained by my genitalia so I just
have to use the magic wand of the trans
prefix and I could be whatever I wish to
be social constructivism is another
Freer from from reality it basically
says that anybody could be the next
Ronaldo or Messi if only mommy hugs me
enough or doesn't hug me enough
all have equal potentiality well that's
a very Noble and hopeful message but
it's perfectly rooted in erroneous views
of human nature also the thing about
Ronaldo and Messi I know Cristiano very
well and interviewed him several times
think about those guys they've got a
phenomenal work ethic and you'll never
hear them either of them whining about
being pushed hard or even having coaches
shout at them or whatever it may be it
just seems to me the world is slowly
shrinking into a very weak-minded place
where weakness is celebrated strength is
somehow frowned upon if you try and talk
about mental strength these days people
go mad they're like no how dare you
you're you're belittling people who
aren't mentally strong you're you're
picking on the vulnerable rather than
accentuate the positives
which those two guys represent better
than anybody
and whether it be the soccer players
that you mentioned or the world that I
inhabit in Academia we used to be proud
of the ethos of meritocracy now that's
viewed as a form of white supremacy now
it's my skin color it's my gender
orientation it's my sexual orientation
it's my religion that actually
adjudicates whether I am right or wrong
it's grotesque it's an attack on the
most fundamental deontological
principles that Define the enlightened
societies that we all are proud of and
this is why I am so irreverent and
fighting against all this nonsense and
it's interesting what you said about
meritocracy there there's a move now for
the Oscars and the academy and the way
they go about you know putting
nominations forward so they have to
particular diversity boxes and that all
sounds fine in principle right till you
get to the point where actually it
damages meritocracy
well and not only that pierce I'm sure
you've also heard that someone should
not play for example you shouldn't play
a gay part if you yourself are not gay
so what does that mean then
Sir Anthony uh Hopkins should not have
played a sadistic serial killer in size
of the Lambs because clearly he's not
really a serial killer it's insane well
not as far as we know but yeah I mean
you're right I mean who plays Hitler who
plays a Mafia Boss right does everyone
in The Sopranos have to actually be an
active member of the mafia I mean and
also it never works the other way with
these these wokies where you never hear
them say and of course the quid pro quo
is that no gay person can play a
straight part they'll never say that
they want all their virtue signaling
cake and eat it
exactly and you know I to your point
earlier about victimhood I come from
Lebanon I escaped execution in Lebanon
and it's folks like me who come to the
West who are you know completely
befuddled by all of the whining I think
you were mentioning to your previous
guess about him whining I despise
whining what's beautiful about Messi and
Ronaldo is this notwithstanding their
innate Talent they work hard to be the
best that they can be we need to return
to that ethos yes we need to start
celebrating proper Talent proper work
ethic people who really want to put a
shift in I mean the work from home
Fiasco and this country is getting
completely out of hand with millions of
people just basically giving up doing
proper work
um you know it's interesting you talk
about professors there because I think
my favorite story of all the cancer
culture stories involved an American
Professor who for 25 years had given a
lecture about offensive language and
eventually a student complained about
his use of offensive language in a
lecture about a offensive language and
he was fired for using offensive
language which he had used to illustrate
the points he was making about offensive
language and at that point I realized
universities are being run by students
and they the students because of his
warped mindset are just running right on
campuses and the campuses and the people
put in charge of these students are just
caving to every one of their whims and
saying okay whatever you say goes
indeed and look I can tell you I just
past semester I was teaching an MBA
class where I was talking about the
evolutionary roots of anorexia nervosa
and in that lecture I talked about
miscarriages and one student huffed and
puffed that I did not provide trigger
warnings before mentioning something as
you know devastatingly sensitive as
miscarriages and this is someone mean
who went through the Lebanese Civil War
so imagine how much disdain I feel for
such an adult an MBA student that he
requires me to offer trigger warnings
before mentioning a medical reality such
as miscarriages it's unbelievable well I
actually need trigger warnings before I
find myself in close proximity to one of
these woke imbeciles because it actually
does bring me out in Wheels again I
could talk to you all night about this
I'm glad we've made up and we're friends
again please come back on on Facebook
when I sent it again I really enjoyed
the chat you're the best and my
apologies to Arsenal next year they'll
take it you know what I'm I'm not so
sure
mentally weak they should have signed
Ronaldo when they had the chance back in
October he wanted to come anyway that's
another story great to talk to you thank
you very much